[Música]
eu amo a minha profissão e vocês amam a
sua
eu sou a inês técnica de enfermagem
trabalha quase 28 anos na uti neonatal
25 anos no mesmo hospital na rede
privada em porto alegre ea minha
profissão é ser mãe é mãe dos bebês e
mães dos pais
lembro de quase todos os meus filhos
embora
são muitos e quando o bebê interna na
uti neonatal nossos deparamos com a
fronteira da vida e da morte pois os
recém nascidos ou frágeis baixo peso
pouca idade gestacional e nós temos a
expectativa sempre que ocorra tudo bem
apesar da gravidade da extremidade da
prematuridade dos bebês
angus assim tão pequenininhos que lhes
cabem na palma das mãos mans
os bebês a termo também interno na uti
lembro do bebê lindo o gordinho pesando
quase quatro quilos
logo que ele nasceu ele ficou com
dificuldade para respirar
precisou internada na uti e foi entubado
e ele desenvolveu a doença chamada
hipertensão pulmonar
muitas vezes levando o paciente a óbito
e foi uma longa caminhada além da
ventilação mecânica
muitas medicações foram administradas e
nós equipe médico enfermeiros
fisioterapeutas agrupá vamos todos os
procedimentos e cuidados como a
administração dos ouros das medicações
a coleta do exame de sangue o exame
clínico do médico a troca de fralda a
fisioterapia
tudo isso para deixar o recém-nascido -
frágil e agitado e os pais sempre
presentes mais limitados a tocar no seu
filho pois até o toque da mãe que
acalenta o bebê para ele era
desconfortável e teve uma manhã que o
quadro clínico piorou muito e o médico
conversou com a família não havia muito
o que fazer pois a ventilação mecânica
estava no máximo às medicações todas
aumentadas
só um milagre a mãe entrou em desespero
e eu me coloquei no lugar dessa mãe
prestes a perder o seu filho
nos abraçamos e choramos juntas
trocamos unimos nossa fé naquele momento
o nosso bebê chegou à fronteira da vida
e eu cuidei muito dessa criança à mãe
sempre presente
ela se sentou ao lado do berço em
silêncio por um longo período ela
acaricia seu filho
nos abraçamos novamente trocamos
palavras de esperança
alcancei um copo d'água se que as
lágrimas do seu rosto
ele disse este menino ainda vai nos dar
muitas alegrias e de fato aos poucos o
quadro clínico foi estabilizando e
melhorando e como foi importante o
cuidar deste bebê porque o cuido e
conforto também os pais é muito difícil
para os pais deixarem os seus filhos
internados na uti
criamos laços e aos poucos eles vão
cansando vão alcançando
a nossa segurança e os medos vão
surgindo para os pais
o maior medo é quando o médico dá
resultado de exames
eles ficam muito fragilizadas porque o
medo de perder o filho dentro de uma
aldeia muito grande então o resultado do
exame que pode estar relacionado a
alguma infecção
o exame de imagem a tomografia a
ressonância ecografia ou até mesmo
quando ele precisa fazer uma transfusão
de sangue
quando o bebê apresenta apnéia que ele
pára de respirar
o alarme dos aparelhos que monitoram o
bebê os pais entrou em pânico e
consequentemente aos poucos nós vamos
desafiar juntando esses desafios juntos
e eles vão ganhando confiança na gente
lembro também das gêmeas que
carinhosamente daí o nome de orquídea e
rosa orquídea nasceu pesando um quilo e
doente doença cardíaca rosa nasceu com 1
quilo e meio saudável
foi uma longa internação quando o médico
deu o diagnóstico da orquídea a família
ficou muito fragilizada
era uma cardiopatia severa que levava
quase 100% óbito
e esse pequeno ser seguiu lutando
ela perdeu muito peso chegou a pesar 700
gramas e o médico conversou com a
família que o melhor momento para a
cirurgia seria quando ela atingisse dois
quilos
estávamos longe de atingir o peso pois a
sua saúde ficava cada vez mais
fragilizada ea perda de peso continuava
estava difícil chegar os dois quilos
no momento ela pesava apenas um eo
médico conversou com os pais
precisava fazer a cirurgia pois o seu
estado de saúde havia se agravado muito
na véspera da cirurgia
a rosa estava muito agitada
desconfortável chorosa
febre teve que dias difíceis
a cirurgia aconteceu a recuperação foi
difícil demorada ea perda de peso
continuava
além da preocupação com as filhas o pai
ficou desempregado momento muito difícil
para a família pois como ficaria o plano
de saúde e aos poucos as meninas foram
melhorando e eu sempre converso
orientando para que ele procure se
manter calmos tranquilos embora as
dificuldades são muito grandes e
orientava a mãe que procurar se ter uma
boa alimentação que descansasse para
poder produzir leite para as meninas e
quando o pac quanto médico liberou 2 ml
de leite materno exclusivo para
orquídeas nossa a felicidade dessa mãe e
o primeiro colo
foi muito emocionante emocionou toda a
equipe trabalhar na uti neonatal é se
doar e a gente vive diariamente a
fronteira da vida e da morte porque
cuidar dos bebês
é uma responsabilidade grande que nós
temos e aos poucos a orquídea rosa foram
melhorando a rosa no desabrochar das
suas flores teve alta com dois meses e
agora o kid enquanto orquídea formando
os seus botões vizinhos teve alta com
cinco meses eu quero dizer a vocês que
eu tenho muitos filhos
embora não seja mãe biológica mas eu
lembro deles e cuido deles com muito
carinho muito amor e se acontece para
vocês quantas crianças do japi day com
certeza mais de 5 mil
eu sou uma mãe que fico muito feliz
quando os meus filhos sai de casa e não
volto
diferente de outras mães
ai eu tenho muito amor à minha profissão
porque quando os bebês interno na uti
nós temos uma responsabilidade muito
grande de cuidá los é a jóia mais
preciosa que os pais deixam aos nossos
cuidados
eu tenho um amor de mãe que acolhe
outras pães um amor de mãe que cuida dos
filhos de outras mães um amor
proporcionado pela minha profissão se eu
amo e tenho muito amor à minha profissão
muito obrigada
[Aplausos]